[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of not
quite as dim as it used to be lighting
oh we're going to be exploring the
question what happens when two friends
go on opposite vacations opposite
vacations well I'll come back to that
but yeah we brighten it up a little bit
I mean not too much
can you go to dim I think yeah I think
we did for a quite a while I just got
tired of looking at you know cuz I watch
I listen back and I watch back yeah we
got to get those views you subscribed
yeah youtube.com slash ear biscuits if
you want to watch us talk and I just was
like I just think it's too dim yeah just
too dim maybe that's the problem maybe
that's our problem it's just too dim we
do it there is no problem we don't have
a problem well you're not in droves
you're not gonna tell them what really
happened what really happened yeah don't
like it Keiko I'm very happy with what
you don't the lighting adjusted a little
bit and it's it's brighter and and we
like it so the question I hope you do is
what happens with two friends going
opposite vacations one to the icy
heights of a mountain and the other to
the fiery depths of that's right I took
I took my wife on a pre Valentine
vacation I know it's Valentine's long
gone by now to to hell to visit Satan
himself vacation hell no no we went to
the to the luxurious Cabo San Lucas
Mexico I love it I love it down there
it's warm there's no snow man it was the
opposite of what you did now I and that
wasn't it I mean people asked if that
was intentional I know a little fire and
I almost posted on I saw what you posted
on Instagram with you lying down in the
sand Oh
shout out to link Lamont on Instagram
you almost forgot your Instagram handle
I wouldn't know I was waiting for you to
take over oh I'm not gonna show you and
I shot me out you shot
it's a beautiful arrangement I was going
to do a post like yours but lying in the
sand I mean in the snow but it was like
Who am I gonna get to take this yeah I
was kind of out there and I'm gonna give
my phone to Shepherd that's not gonna
work so I just took a picture of my face
probably got more likes anyway that's
not what it's about for me man it's
about my personal let's not get back in
it don't go there but yeah we're like
fire and ice vacations which reminds me
of Fire and Ice the basketball players
from North Carolina State University's
Court Gianni and Rodman ruh-roh
Ronnie Monroe so who's Chris Guccione
who's Ronnie Monroe Chris Corti on Inc
was the was the point guard he was the
dribbler and the pastor Ronnie Monroe
was the to guard always shooting the
shots but who do you think you know who
was far a nice are you asking me Iceman
which one of us is good this course
eonni was the point guard and Ronnie
Monroe was it too but which one's fire
nice oh that is a good question I know I
think well when you're on fire you're
making baskets and when you ice you're
like you're cool under pressure so one
of them was making lots of baskets and
the other one I think Chris Court Gianni
was ice cuz Chris Guccione was fired
because he was like super into like
crayon and around like crazy with rock
rodney was cool as ice and smooth super
smooth and this is like the early 90s
mmm this is the late 80s really I think
pretty sure yeah but who of us is the
fire and who's the ice I'm the fire down
in Cabo I'm like Chris Guccione
running around on the beaches you're
like ice up there freezing your took us
off trying to ski I'll take that I'll
take ice
Ronnie Monroe had a um close cropped
haircut with one line carved in it and
it was in the middle I believe I think
it moved from time to time it depended
his mood it's kind of like the I show
glaciers you're kind of slowly shifting
Crisco Johnny became a real estate agent
in Raleigh and his son played for state
but did not get a lot of PT I think it
was what they call a legacy a legacy
spot on the team okay and but if we're
talking about it and everybody's riveted
that's we don't know we'll have any idea
what you're talking about
before we get into our vacation I say
you know as is the ear biscuit practice
to bring each other fully up to speed on
what happened because we kept it from
each other in order to share it with
each other in you at the same time may I
give a blow dryer relationship update
because in a in a recent ear biscuit
conversation I was talking about
blow-drying my body with my hair dryer
when I get out of the shower and you
said you two you've talked about that
before you're always talking about it
and that's right I got it I got an
update
matter-of-fact okay keep talking about
it in I've got a I got a PSA a public
service announcement that I discovered
this morning ladies and gentlemen if you
like me take a shower exit the shower
and then go straight to your hair dryer
blow dry or whatever you want to call it
turn that thing on to give yourself a
nice crisp and warm dry feeling not only
on your hair not only on your armpits
but also in your crotch area like I
unapologetically do with no judgment
from my tall friend with a furrowed
eyebrows then I've got news for you take
your old toothbrush like I did this
morning I don't know what you think I'm
about to say but it's not that bad okay
take the back off of your blow-dryer and
brush the back of your blow-dryer cuz
that vent where it sucks in all the air
is getting it's getting clogged up with
dust and whatnot I looked at the back of
my hairdryer and that thing just had a I
was like it looks dusty in there
I gotta get a toothbrush to get it out
and I got I thought about filming this
for my Instagram I should have done it
it would it was so satisfying to brush
out all of you took you took you
unscrewed the back there was like or
just did there was a superficial filter
like a netting thing on the outside and
then there was another filter hidden
inside of there and it was easily turn a
little bit and pull it off and whoa
there it is and I tooth brushed out all
of this lint I'm like man this is
satisfying
I should have instagrammed it now we're
back to where I was in this story then
I'm like okay improve the blood I put
the cap back on it no exaggeration three
times the blowing power you're really
clogged up like him how old is this how
long he had this dryer you sure maybe
you have your own dryer and your wife
has a different one I'm Sharon Christy
came in right after I'd finished and
still naked but totally dry everywhere
she couldn't find a wet spot on me I
could have rolled around in flour and
nothing would have stuck well she said
she didn't say anything in fact I said
Christy and I pulled out my toothbrush
I'm like you can use my toothbrush to
clean out your hairdryer she's like I
use that one I'm like cool
you use this one well I got news for you
you're about to get three times the
blowing power you thought she had her
own hair dryer I thought she did yeah
well you guys need to talk more it was
in the middle drawer but I thought she
had one over there and I thought it was
exclusive I didn't realize I was doing
her a big favor and I was disappointed
when she wasn't as excited as I was but
she didn't turn it off tomorrow morning
she's gonna turn that thing off
it's gonna blow her away he's gonna blow
her across the room she's gonna she's
gonna hit the back wall maybe you need
it was amazing air filter in your
bathroom if you've got that much dust
mm-hmm that's a good point because the
only thing this filtering right now is
the hairdryer
it's occasionally use oh no I don't use
it a case like they use it the lung of
your bathroom
that's right do you are you are use your
I know you squeegee towel off and then
you blow-dry all right guys he's engaged
he's engaged in this conversation yeah I
fully I squeeze you in my hands I but
you don't with the you're fully become a
lot II you you cut you go head underarms
and crotch
I tell off every square inch of my body
but we'll take you low dryer but you
know I go up and down your legs with the
blow dryer know the only the only the
hairiest areas need to be blowed okay do
you blow dried it's your hair in that
moment yeah so you get your hair
completely dry I get it where you style
it I now that my hair is a little longer
it helps I use Les Paul made that way
you know that I recently not recently
but like in the past
mythical pomade I might add year and a
half to two years basically all my adult
life I had blow-dried my hair as I was I
mean ever since the hairs gone up which
is for a decade or whatever yeah III
blow-dried or is it blue dried blue dry
well what what verb do you conjugate
when in blow dry balloon blown dried
blown dried yeah I've blown dried my
hair for a decade and then I decided to
stop dry blown doing that and instead I
towel dry the hair just a little bit
yeah and then I put the pomade I put the
mythical pomade in my hair while it is
wet and let it air dry I've been there
and that creates more activity in my
hair you know more interest more of a
wave but then I have to sometimes even
pay more attention to my hair after I
get to work cause it's like it's dry and
then I got a fiddle with it again and
that's kind of what pain if you want
height you want your hair to be drier
when you apply product
I'm not saying fully dry but if you want
interest in activity yeah you might want
to stay you might want to stay away from
the blow dryer I have
touched a blow dryer in years I I'll
give you all the lutein months from my
blow dryer you can deposit it in the
back of your blow dryer then use it well
I kind of will be sewing attic my wife
got the Dyson that I don't know where
the filter is in fact it seems like
$5,000 but it seems like magic it's just
a circle it's the same thing that Anna
uses here I'm kind of jealous one of
those it's not $5,000 but it is a that
is the most excited is an expensive
hairdryer
I've been thinking about getting one
because you can't put a toothbrush in it
I'll tell you that much don't try that
so what we can keep listening about this
for hashtag air biscuits let me know how
much better your life is now that your
hairdryer has been brushed and we are
gonna talk about our fire and ice'
vacations but first we're gonna let you
know that you can pick up links very
meta your biscuits shirt that he's
wearing while making an ear biscuit at
mythical dot store man we got your
biscuits on everything we got it on the
sign we get it on my chest we got it on
my what's this dinnerware well you can
put it you can usually just call it
drink we're drink well but you could
have it at dinner I guess also mythical
pomade pick that up and mythical hair
dryers
we don't have those yet but maybe we
should let's compete directly with Dyson
that sounds like a great business
strategy okay so have we want to do this
I mean I could talk more about hair
dryers I had a hair idea for a hair
dryer this exclusively for men I know
that sounds sexist but that's what
marketing is just who do who do like BS
like a man and a woman's hair dryer need
not be different I mean my wife and I
not to my knowledge but in in fact
trueness do use the same hair dryer but
men and women can use the same hair
dryer but do you convince men and women
that they had need to have different
hair dryers like like they've convinced
women that they have have they have to
have a different razor they've done it
they convinced them they did it they've
convinced men that they have to have
different hair dye right yo yes yes just
for men yeah you got it your hair is
different right
unnaturally dark for way too long and
you need to get a crib yeah they've done
that very successfully right we can do
that with a hair dryer right it's called
the pro drive convinced women that they
have to have a razor did you hear that
the bro dryer that's good well I don't I
just made that up I think it's great
marketing I don't want to feed into it
yeah I don't want to feed into making
men and women think that they have to
have different products to serve the
same purpose Oh without testicles
hanging from it oh he's got a beard hang
it from a bulbous pink thing that looks
like an alien remote control in order to
shave their legs they don't know that
that's right that's right but they men
needed their own blow dryer I do like
that broader idea gets the job done the
bro dryer gets the job done that's this
that's the slogan yeah you know come to
think of it I did just on Instagram by a
writ AAA shaver what that was that is
intended for manscaping okay only not
woman escaping
you can't escape a woman right but it's
like you don't need that I loved
watching you it's just like every night
if you were gonna share this that like
you had fallen for your own tricks and
then there's a they they sent me these
wipes min wipes and it said ball wipes
on them oh gosh seriously yeah I was
like what wipe my balls I don't know
what yeah I haven't opened them can I
borrow a few okay let's talk about this
bro so you went to Mammoth I went to me
we teased all this I mean so in the last
episode we party no go to Mammoth so
I'll just get right to it
Fire and Ice it's never been more
fitting because speaking of ice I know I
I think I said this in a in a tweet or
an Instagram or something I don't know
but Twitter is fresh is this about to be
between
the week of so the weekend before I got
to Mammoth to ski they received 11 feet
of snow he received it they received it
now 11 feet is a is a crap-ton of snow
that's an unbelievable amount of snow I
mean we're talking like basketball
backboard height but halfway up the
backboard now the weekend I was there
like Ronnie Monroe would have trouble
with that they received another four
feet of snow so by the time all was said
and done 15 feet of snow Wow
and I was well at least it's good to
know that global warming isn't a thing
there's nothing you know forget about
climate change
I see what you're where you're going
with that link mm-hmm links being
sarcastic
I think understands the difference
between climate and weather unlike some
people who tweet quite a bit about that
I'm pushing retz button right now so I
am I was nervous about the trip because
we had to leave for London which we'll
talk about next
next week we teaser we had to leave for
London the day after I got back that
like the morning after I got back yeah
and if you get back I mean with 1211
feet of snow and I knew this other storm
was coming in and I was just like I've
heard and then I was talking to someone
I don't know who I can't remember was
but they were they were like last time I
went to Mammoth I got snowed in in fact
last couple of times I went to Mammoth
I've gotten snowed in it was like I
can't miss I can't not go to London and
so I'm beginning to worry and I want to
be very prepared now I know that once
you go up into the mountains a lot of
times chains will be required for your
tires now in previous trips to Mammoth
we've an Big Bear we've had to have
chains for the tires in the car like
carrying chains is required in the
winter if you're gonna go to these
mountainous regions right and I am
assuming that applies to lots of places
around the country
the world yeah but I've never had to
apply them and this is one of those
moments worse like dad mode engaged
oh you know what I mean and I'm like
okay it is possible that I go up there
and I get to a spot in the road and
they've got a sign that says chains
required and at that point I got to put
the chains on the tires and so I feel
like I got a practice okay so you bought
the chains well so turns out that the
chains that I had weren't quite the
right size I put them on for you they
were here for for your previous car you
owned them or you you you ordered the
wrong ones I think that Jesse had gone
to throw and Jesse under the bus no no
she what she went and told him what kind
of car we had and then they gave us the
chains at like a by a you know an
autozone or something like that and they
just gave us the wrong ones
I'm not so it wasn't autozone I don't
know what it was I don't want to throw
any particular chain under the bus
hahahaha chain
but the get it but it was yeah I don't
think she said this is exactly the size
of tire so it probably would have worked
but then when I called my local place
after I put these ones on and you were
in your driveway you were like a home
put on the driveway practicing and they
were too big they're a little bit too
big how would you would you have known I
wouldn't have known if they were to be
how would you have guessed that the
chains go onto your tires you lay it out
you drive on it exactly you pick it up
like a diaper on a baby and you link it
on the outside not how it happens
that's what I thought it would have been
- okay you do not you do not drive onto
it you take it at least the ones that I
that I got you the car is stationary and
you drape the chain over the tire okay
and then you reach around the bottom
fasten and then you come around the top
around the front and fasten and then
there's like a tensioner that tightens
it and then they give you this extra
thing that's like a bungee cord with
hooks on it and
grabs the ring that's on this side of
the outside of the tire and kind of hard
tightens everything down it's actually
and I'm sure there's other ones that go
on differently but it's remarkably easy
I got the kind that but you could tell
that it was too big yeah but then I went
and got the right ones and practiced
again and I was like I think I can do
this oh wow that was the time that you
spent that you could have been putting
on my carrier that you refused and I'm
still kind of sour about I'm glad I
didn't take their carrier because the
place I stayed the clearance for parking
was six foot eight and my car would have
been too tall with the carrier okay well
that's good for both I would have just
taken your carrier and I would have just
set it in the snow somewhere I would
have gotten four feet on top of it and
it would still be in Mammoth under snow
so you're welcome for not taking your
carrier I get up to Mammoth and I
started to see that lots of snow like it
went from no snow like I can't imagine
11 feet of snow ever drew or driven up
never driven up no never been up there
so you drive through this thing called
the Owens Valley which is there's all
this history of the Owens Valley and how
there was this giant lake up there and
then Mulholland who Mulholland Drive is
named after and lots of things in LA are
named after that guy Owen Wilson's
hanging out up there Terrell Owens this
guy owned or worked for the LADWP
Department of Water and Power and then
he bought a bunch of land all the
privately available land in this valley
and that gave him the water rights to
this giant lake that they basically
drained and this is where we where la
got a bunch of its water from and now
all this water that comes into this
valley is pumped to Los Angeles it's
quite quite interesting if you're
interested in the history of the water
of Los Angeles
that's another podcast but anyway the
trip up there is just this desolate
nothingness with a couple of towns that
you come to like to be a town and it'll
be like 50 miles and nothing except just
these mountain ranges on each side we
went through but beautiful beautiful
absolutely beautiful you know lone pine
you probably heard of this town there's
been like a hundred movie shot in Lone
Pine including Django Unchained and
a bunch of other ones that you've heard
of uh-huh and the mountains right
outside of Lone Pine
look I kind of looked at I was like that
looks like the Himalayas like the way
that it was these Rocky Mountains just
straight rocks uh-huh with snow on them
and then I started reading about it on
my phone once I was up at Mammoth they
were like often filmmakers used the
mountains outside of Lone Pine to pass
for the Himalayas in low-budget movies
was I didn't you feel you felt
low-budget validated anyway we get very
close to Mammoth and I see the sign
chains required in my heart rate goes up
a little bit yeah yeah I'm like this is
the moment of truth I've got to pull off
to the side of the road keep in mind
that not only are they getting snow but
it's seven degrees ooh was it snowing at
Des Moines at that time it was just a
little teeny bit of snow it was there's
snow on the street no snow on the ground
the snow first of all I wasn't all the
way to Mammoth and so they the machines
they have that get the snow off of the
road it's it's absolutely amazing how
efficient they are at getting mounds and
mounds of snow off of the road and then
of course because they sawed the road
there was nothing on the road it was
completely dry but it was like
preemptively putting on chains okay some
people weren't stopping some people I
found out later why some people were
continuing to go but I pull over I was
so prepared
I had a headlamp was it night it was
already dark wanted to wear a headlamp
I've had it I had a headlamp I had
another little light that I put under
the car I had a tarp or a tarpaulin is
the full name for that kept our Polian
yeah and I said you'd get down on the
ground you laid out a blanket for us I'd
added so hard you're out on that tarp
look it's take a picture of me laying
out on a on a tarp and I there's people
going my headlamp going past me you know
and I'm out there on the tarp and
reaching around and clamping it down and
hoping that I'm not endangering the
lives of my children and wife yeah that
God doesn't use a blow dryer I have in
Chile got it on sticks his head
out the window of his Harley and then I
get back into the car and I start
driving down the dry pavement with the
chains on the tires they can't be good
and then I'm like and where's the snow
like I don't feel right about this I'm
like Jessie Google how fast I was going
like 40 I was like Google how fast you
should go with chains on your tires on
dry pavement cuz what did it feel like
if that was crazy but when you get to a
certain speed it kind of just all blends
together and it just kind of becomes us
low hum it's good I mean just literally
your rubber tires are wrapped in chains
yeah crazy anyway 20 20 to 30 30 miles
per hour and so I slowed it down it took
like 45 minutes to go the last like 10
miles and eventually once we got to
Mammoth there's still no snow like the
very little snow on there's a couple of
icy patches or whatever but chains were
still required but once you got into
town that was when they had taken it was
like driving through a corn maze but the
corn was snow so like you're out you
can't see anything except these huge
snowbank like shops everywhere like I
don't know how they so quickly got
access to everything like every parking
lot in every restaurant and every shop
was completely cleared but they had just
moved all the snow and snow obviously
compacts a whole lot like if you've got
11 feet of snow 15 feet of snow that's
just falling fresh you can squish all
that down into I don't know a couple of
feet but they probably had salted it so
the stuff melted it wasn't like the
Imbros which the road was still dry but
you were driving through this corn maze
Seaview snow do you do you take photos
of this now did it was anybody else
driving with chains yeah once I got into
town everybody had a mom everybody cuz
it was your validated it was required
cuz you were thinking maybe I should
pull over and take him back off and that
would be admitting defeat yeah but it
was just one of those moments where I
was just ads don't do that I could have
paid in fact there were dudes out there
yeah don't defeat charging $40 for to
put the chains on for you just to put
them on they didn't have
Cheng's they just had the service start
polling him probably yeah and they were
like dressed like firemen which i found
interesting and ironic considering you
drawn a fire vacation right so we all
right so we got you to Mammoth let's get
me to Cabo now I went to a place that
I've been three years earlier Chris you
know I went to this place I'll give a
shout-out to the Cape I I really enjoy
it it's a nice spot I've been there once
not a sponsor I recommended it to you
and you went and then I decided I was
gonna go back and I did mm-hmm
of course when you went back a few
months back you didn't go back to the
same place she went to a different place
nothing against the Cape nothing against
the Cape but for me it's like I knew
what I was gonna get and I wanted more
of it I'm always up for a new thing I
just I just wanted to try something yeah
sometimes I sometimes I want the same
thing and if I hadn't had tried
something new I wouldn't have gotten
Gary to take that frickin picture of me
and my watermelon outfit which brought
me back to what so again I'm not
faulting you I'm just happy there's a
little different psychology here between
the two of us you know first of all it
was a shorter it was just a you know a
short well a longer weekend so a shorter
vacation wasn't like a whole week so I
just wanted to have this relaxing
poolside plate in place that I was gonna
go to you know and I could count on it
because I only had a couple of days to
make the most of it it started out much
better cuz the previous time that we
went we were flying down there and some
we were getting on the plane and the
first class was already on and we had
some friend I'll call him acquaintances
well let's call him friends people who
knew us reckon you knows like hey
recognize this and we went back and once
we got in the air they sent back some
champagne to us oh the the the flight
attendant came up and said this is from
your friends in first class and they
brought they gave us champagne or
mimosas their friends it was um it was
uh ran and you know it was them Oh
so anyway
we drink the champagne and I think there
was this we a weird interaction I I'm I
don't know for sure but I think that
Christy had taken an anxiety medication
because she has problems with flying yes
and then we we by the time we got off
the plane she's not feeling great and
then we had to take this taxi it's like
a 25 minute drive so we're like taking a
taxi to the place and like she's not
she's not looking like she feels great
this isn't this vacation starting great
fire vacation fire alarm and literally
when we pulled up to the place and they
like open the door and they're like
hello welcome to the resort like like
grand entrance type welcome situation
and it's a beautiful place like right
when you walk up to check-in you're like
looking out over the the beach and it's
amazing and as I'm walking up Chris he's
like I've got to find a bathroom and
like she bolts past me and like I'm
taking in this wonderful view and I just
had this image of Chris's like sprinting
past me sprinting past the reception
area turns out she asked them where's
the nearest restroom but I feel so far
ahead of me I just looked like she
didn't even stop it just disappears she
eventually comes out until they she'd
found a bathroom she was like throwing
up in the bathroom and stuff and then
she had to go up to the right we checked
into the room she had to like lay down
for two hours
it's a horrible beginning of that
vacation after that everything got a lot
better for her well yeah you know that's
one way to see it you start that low
I don't you're gonna have a good time I
don't maybe I threw her under the bus
with this whole medication champagne
thing but uh that's what happened and
then so this time we didn't make any of
those mistakes we get there and
everything was good so we got there all
in one piece and I mean the theme of my
vacation was I don't want to see no
mountains I want to see no snow I don't
want to do anything active like skiing I
wanted to do the opposite of you I
wanted to delay flat
on the sand take one picture for
Instagram and I want to lay flat on a
lounger drink some drinks read some
books be with my lovely wife that's it
and mission accomplished man it was
great
especially because it didn't start off
with her sprinting past me
there was no sprinting to any restrooms
so that's now my like measurement of
success for you it's did I actually need
the chains did you uh did you have a
photo shoot no photo shoot didn't need
it again I got my picture I got my
picture i splayed out well my vacation
was definitely very active and it was my
intention in going on this trip was this
is practice for our Spring Break
vacation which is also skiing a week of
skiing you're really doubling down on
skiing like this is what this is the
year of just this is the year of trying
it now I you know I talked about this
when we did our top moments of 2018 and
remember skiing as a family was yeah one
of my top ten and so I really want to
enjoy that week you know and it there's
a little bit of a dad kind of making
everybody do this element - yeah the
skiing thing cuz jesse is cheap she can
ski but she got hurt last time she went
and she's just like I'm just gonna go
and I'm gonna read and that's what she's
gonna do when we go to spring break
she's actually looking forward to just
relaxing and lodging it up yeah and so
but I was like okay so this is me
basically about me kind of getting the
kids a little bit better so they can
really enjoy and also so they can we can
all kind of keep up with each other so
Shepherd can keep up with with me and
Locke and I'm no expert so I don't and I
keep it pretty slow but Locke sprained
his ankle three days before we left like
bad enough that he couldn't ski yeah I
mean it's still he wouldn't build a ski
right now it's good there's he
gonna be well just when we're going Oh
Colorado and at that point he may get
ring injured who knows
hopefully not what was he like were you
there when the engine in a game or
something yeah a basketball practice it
wasn't a game price was he like
wallowing around on the ground I wasn't
there I just knew that he thought he had
broken it it was it was a like a bad
sprain like one of those it like stays
with you for a while and sometimes bad
sprains can be worse than breaks but
it's not that bad it's not like a high
with a high sprain I think it's a low
spring did you ask him if he cried uh no
I think he said he wanted to he was like
it hurt so bad I wanted to cry yeah but
you know McLaughlin's we don't cry oh
gosh and we don't take the chains off
once we put them on that's not healthy
man you need that you need to pass along
some well I I think you should be able
to cry I know you're joking I think you
should be able to cry from feelings
emotional feelings but the physical hurt
I think you got to keep the tears inside
I think that's especially at 14 I'm a
little you're almost a man well I'm
concerned about okay so it's just you
and Shepard out there but eleven feet of
snow I know that that at a certain point
it gets a lot more difficult to see yeah
well it had gotten that and I recess you
get because when we went the the first
time the last time we went with our
friend Eric Park City I was still
snowboarding you were trying to ski you
had switched anyway we were currently
that's the story where I lost my phone
and in the blizzard oh yeah probably
have told that but it was very similar
to that that if skiing and powder and
fresh powder snow is a completely
different experience especially when you
really I into skiing last year so or two
years ago so it's yeah it was it was
very difficult when I got into the plate
you know and I will tell you exactly how
difficult it was when I got to the top
of the mountain but I recently upped the
douche factor in my life you know I'm
always trying to do that a little bit I
didn't know you had any more margin by
getting my own custom fitting ski boots
but yeah this is I mean I'm getting into
this at this point and you go and you
rent the my feet are done growing right
you go ones bigger than the other
right and you go and you rent and you
you never know what you're gonna get you
never know what's gonna end up hurting
while you're out there and there's
everybody's like you got to get the
custom fitting boots and there's a
custom insert so I went to this place in
Studio City I can't remember the name of
it but I highly recommend the ski boot
fitting place in Studio City and they
the guy spends time with you and you
take your shoes off and he like put your
foot in this mold and he makes basically
a custom insert to go into this thing
and picks the right boot for you based
on your foot shape that like I'm mold
like they poured something around your
know if they don't pour it you put your
foot into this like slime inflatable
almost like memory foam ish type pad and
you press down and then it this the
weird vacuuming thing is taking place
and then you bring your foot off of it
and your footprint is completely stuck
so it's really the bottom of your foot
and then with the sides of your foot he
gets in a different way I don't know it
takes like an hour and a half it's
pretty high-tech stuff so did you
experience the benefit of that skiing
they're vulnerable
yes it was dramatically better when your
foot is written the thing that most
people don't realize and I was one of
these people is that your ski boots
should be much tighter than you think it
should be so that your foot is any
movement inside the boot is being
immediately transferred into leverage
you know I'm saying because yeah it's a
little bit loose yeah you move your leg
and then you hit the side of the boot
and so if you really want the response
if you're just if you're yeah if you're
like a you know near expert downhill
skier like I am so it might be a little
overkill because I'm nefeli not an
expert that was sarcasm
I am a 100% of the time thinking don't
get hurt don't get hurt don't get hurt
don't get hurt don't get hurt don't get
hurt don't get hurt even while I'm
having a great time I never lose that
don't get hurt don't get hurt and I've
learned that I don't think that's what a
lot
the people going the mountain down the
mountains or thinking about I think
they're thinking about oh that looks
cool do that and I'm thinking don't get
hurt
that looks cool do that hmm but I was
thinking where did my menu go like I was
gonna order like some fish tacos but I
cannot find a menu where's the waiter oh
there is come on here's the menu it's
like that was kind of the adversity that
I that I faced well I had oh I had I
faced a little adversity okay well I had
a moment of what I thought was what
could be near death so you want me to
save that I'll save it actually I had a
near-death experience okay I got a
massage we always give our massage
updates we probably talked about
massages more than anything I'm
blow-dryers starting to uh it's starting
to vibe for that position for me at
least but these are the things you look
forward to as your body Blaster age I
told her that my hip flexors really
messed up ever since I kicked that
soccer ball and Thanksgiving and I was
like go hard or go home but don't go
home so you know what that means and of
course you told her to go hard and then
I like I said right here it's really
hurting like I was pointed like where am
i a hip flexor right where the top of my
my femur hits my is my thigh mm-hmm or
hits my my pelvis and I'll tell you
right now she was she was stretching me
out of course I was naked under the
sheet so it's like she had this way to
like take the sheet and Christy was also
in there with another masseuse it was
like a couples massage thing but she
would turn me over on my side and like
pick my leg up like trying to stretch it
but she would haven't she'd wrapped the
sheet like I was wrapping a baby in a
cloth diaper like that's what she was
doing to me yeah but at certain points
my entire butt cheek was exposed and
like my my knee was being pushed up
across my body that's the best part of
the massage though it hurt really badly
because of this injury I have and I
don't know that she made it better
because
still hurting but yeah well I'll put it
to you this way you know how when you're
grilling chickens and if you like if
you've only cut the dark meat separate
from the white meat so you've got like a
thigh and a leg that's still together
yeah
and then you you want to know if it's
done but if you if you're a little
anxious to get it on the table and
everyone's eating cuz it's getting a
little late and everybody's hungry and
you're like dad where's the chicken you
take it off a little early never do that
and then so you don't get that when you
grab the chicken leg you can break it
from the thigh a little give and then
you're sitting there grabbing the
chicken leg before you know it you're
like ham-fisted grabbing your thigh with
one hand and the chicken leg with the
other hand and you're just wrenching
them apart to try to pull apart and have
a leg experience separate from a thigh
experience gotta be careful with that
though and you're just trying to get all
the way out right you'll get the thigh
bone out of all the thigh meat stuck to
the end of the drumstick oh I was
thinking the opposite sometimes you pull
the drumstick right out of the thigh
either way he's not good when the
analogy is to my body I felt sure that
was gonna happen I doubt that she could
pull it out I mean it was like it would
I did I was just having imagery of that
MORTAL KOMBAT finishing move where like
it got pulls the head and the spine out
of the body it's like he's gonna push
she's gonna pull my leg did you make any
grunts or did you make any signals that
I was breathing so heavily that Christy
told me afterward that she almost asked
me to be quiet
like not she didn't ask me you are you a
massage you be quiet she's like why are
you breathing so loud I looked over at
she's like did you see me in my diaper
cause you were in pain I love the pain
but I got a go to physical therapy for
this thing swords yes still hurts
that's my near-death experience top that
okay so because it was snowing so much
hey next time you eat a chicken leg
think of me and because it was so windy
the top of the mountain was closed for a
couple of reason
like they're worried about visibility
and avalanches and wind gusts like the
wind gusts at the top of the mountain
were over 50 miles per hour and so
they're very like hesitant to open at
the mountain but I'm with my friend
Ralph who is from Switzerland
yeah he's Swiss and so this guy like
what they come out of the womb with skis
on you know I'm saying they know how to
point him in the in toes first it's just
it's really difficult if you come out
headfirst and you then you've got skis
on yeah you have to use the forceps it's
very difficult but they cut there they
come out of the womb and they just go
right down the mountain they learn to
ski before they can walk and right so
it's a little intimidating on pregnant
women give birth at the top of slopes
right well you're always on a slope and
so the I'm the cheese is holy I was a
little I'm a little intimidated you know
me
like if something well I know you you
didn't say anything right so when raus
like oh they opened up lifts so and so
and you're like and he knows the whole
mountain saying anything and he's like
you you want to go and I'm like uh yeah
you know I'm not gonna say no right
again there's just something there's
something in me that I can't I can't
sustain there on the tire I can't say no
you asked me to you challenge me to do
something I'm gonna get on the lift even
though the whole time I'm thinking I'm
not equipped I'm not equipped for this
something in you don't know what I will
encounter at the top because I don't
know if you've established it not an
expert I don't handle the double black
diamonds very well well going all the
way to the top gives you much more
opportunity to constantly think don't
hurt yourself don't hurt so first of all
let me just remind you how cold it was
so we're talking about like - 15 - 20
windchill because you're getting to the
top of the mountain and you got this
these wind gusts and I like fully
prepared I mean I was like double
thermals and I'm not talking like
thermals Walmart thermals I'm talking
about like Patagonia expensive Oh
high-tech stop I will stop bragging
about all those no no equipment you've
been by no because I'm explaining how
much how warm I was it's the type that
when you look at the liner it looks like
aluminum foil the kind that have like
special loops for your thumbs to like
keep it really tight on your wrist and
then I've got some high-tech glove
liners underneath my gloves I have this
crazy thing that's I have a helmet of
course but underneath my helmet it's a
ski mask that magnetically fastens over
my face like this it has a little hole
for your nose and then the only thing
showing is your eyes because it goes up
under your helmet and so then there was
literally no skin exposed no skin
exposed whatsoever and I'm going up this
lift a what is the logo for douche brand
free first of all let me explain every
single person on the mountain looks like
me so it's I wasn't standing at all when
is this cold if you don't have the
proper equipment you're going to suffer
greatly because I was well you did high
I did have the right equipment and I was
already freezing like with glove liners
and gloves by the time I got to the top
I couldn't feel my fingers sounds like
fun
so we get off at the top and you hadn't
even almost died yet it has picked the
wind has picked up the snow has picked
up I could see nothing like it was just
complete whiteout up there and like I'm
like Ralph but they don't let you back
down and like that continue listening
friend so we go down and there's this I
get up there and at this point I'm like
Ralph I don't know if I can do this is
like I just come with me and we go down
this little incline and then we get to a
place where we kind of have to make a
decision and we're not gonna go down the
crazy crazy it says experts only he says
I won't take you down that we go down
there's another option and I see people
going it hasn't been groomed and it's
just like 2 or 3 feet of powder and
people people who look like they can ski
and snowboard are going off this thing
and then immediately just falling into
this the snow and like their skis are
going you know this you were when we
were with Eric your snowboard or skis
get in the powder and then you've got to
have somebody help you out yeah and I
was like Ralph if we go this way
I'm gonna be like turning falling
turning falling all the way down the
mountain I was like in an hour and a
half I got to get Shepard from this
lesson because let he was doing a lesson
that day I was like honestly I don't
think it would be wise and I don't want
to do this to you I want you to enjoy it
so what I'm gonna do is like you go
ahead I'm gonna go first of all we're
its it where it's like we're on what's
the the Tatooine yeah I'm like yelling I
like the crazy wind and snow Utama ha ha
yeah I was on Tatooine ha I had a drink
in my hand and so I walk I take my skis
off and begin walking back up to and of
course I had skied down to this I'd
probably skied 75 yards but it takes no
time to do that walking back up the hill
mm-hmm my boots were going into the snow
up to my knees hold on you were walking
back to what back to this to the lifts
to tell the lift operator I want to get
on the lift and go down the lift to get
back down good good on you but I start
walking back up the hill and I'm like I
don't think I'm going to be able to get
to the lift that's impossible because
the snow is so deep and then I start
breathing so hard like where was it up
to your knees yeah to my knees but I
kept going it took a very long time to
get back to the lift and I get to lift
there's nobody there but there's a
little house with like someone in it
like either the operator or whatever are
you visibly crying at this point cuz
that would help I'm getting close but
you can't but you can't even tell who I
am which at this point I'm very happy
about okay you can't identify me at all
so I go up to and first of all there's
so much snow that you don't care about
dying you really care most about not
being identified while almost dying you
can't even get into the thing so I'm
like waving at this girl who is inside a
cottage just the cottage and she comes
out and she opens the door and has this
annoyed look on her face just - right
from the start and I'm like yeah I think
maybe I've gotten in over my head
Hey and and I'm like my friend taught me
to come up here and I'm not sure I can
get down
and ah and she says and I'm like is
there any way that I can get on the lift
and go back down and she's like no no
and she slammed the cottage door and I'm
like but what do I do she's like just go
back the way you came and just stay
straight okay take it slow you'll be
fine and now I'm like Ralph is gone my
buddy and the buddy systems go is gone
and so now I'm gonna have to be getting
assistance from strangers and by the way
the wind has picked up she's like on the
radio like saying we might have to shut
it down like there's not gonna be
anybody to take me down though every
time people are coming up they're
falling off of the lift because the
thing is the crazy wind is gone so now
I'm thinking I'm gonna go down the
mountain
I'm already freezing I'm gonna get stuck
I'm going to be a popsicle in the
morning
this is it I'm going to freeze on top of
the mountain so I go back to where we
had to make the decision which way did
you say thanks I almost at that point
again I'm dealing with my pride the
whole time like I can't I'm not yeah but
at that point when she's like you can't
do it you've got to go I'm like well I
guess I had to do it at that point
there's no option so I go back and at
this point I'm asking everyone to make
sure that I like literally every person
like do you know the easiest way down
like I'm confirming like every seven
feet is this the easiest way down and it
turns out that the way Ralph went was
not the easiest way and I would have
been in real trouble if I had had gone
where he did and it turned out that
there was a slight the slight incline
continued again I couldn't see like he
couldn't tell if you were about to go
off the side it was like very very
unsettling and eventually I got to go
through this whiteout area and then got
into a place where they had groomed the
snow way up the mountain at that point I
was able to to get down I I survives man
I I don't I'm proud of you for you know
for for just for saying you know what I
need help I can't do this yeah but then
I just I don't feel great about what
happened because she kind of forced you
to push through and I kind of I kind of
feel like the best thing for you would
have been for her to say something like
okay we're gonna take you down you're
gonna be safe but we're gonna strip you
nude and we're gonna put a banner on it
that says whoops
and it's and we're gonna we're gonna
kind of parade you in front of everybody
made it like a real painful emotional
situation I feel like this became like a
triumph that you survived a survival
tale I wouldn't call it a triumph if you
had a see if you had a witness that you
would not have considered it a triumph
okay see you let you did learn a lesson
yeah I learned I'm not gonna listen to
Ralph anymore
when he says to go up this go over the
frickin lift in those conditions but
he's not your friend but ultimately I
had an incredible time the second day
when it led up a little bit
Shepard was done with this lesson me and
him went out I got some of that on the
Instagram story shot out read him see
the McLaughlin boys but at least two of
them are taking the mountain by storm
that's Shepard Locke sprained his ankle
loser got the good stuff but like he's
getting so much better and he's like
fearless and he's there's so much to
know that there was literally like
typically when you go to a to a
California ski resort there's snow on
the on the like this slope that you're
on but in like in the trees there's not
there was snow on every single square
inch of the mountain you go absolutely
anywhere Wow we saw a dude as we were
going up the gondola a guy who had gone
down the side of the mountain at the top
and gotten stuck on the side of a cliff
and his snowboard was like on two peaks
and he was sitting there holding him
self up like at the top of a cliff and
ski patrol was trying to get down there
and like lower something to him to bring
him back up like he had stopped inches
short of going over a cliff
yeah like and dying people were going
everywhere because snow is everywhere
and at the top of this mountain it's
like I'm talking like ski adventure Ski
YouTube compilation level Mountain at
the top of this thing is ridiculous
crazy man
but Shepard is like going into the trees
and doing he's a nut listen he was
having incredible it reminds me of the
pool at this resort I was right yeah
yeah I mean it started really shallow
like getting up so it's just angle deep
and then all of a sudden I'm walking I'm
walking I'm like this is like knee deep
and then all of a sudden whoa boom over
your head there was a step and it was
like up to my belly button I put in that
pool and then I kept walking and walking
and then before I knew it BAM
I ran smack dab into a bar on the other
side of the pool that served drinks oh
really
extreme man extreme stuff glad you made
it out alive
yeah did you get me help well he made
the drink for me I didn't even have to
do it and then after I drank the drink I
had to I had to walk all the way back Oh
two men carried the drink through the
pool he couldn't swim with the drink I
just elected to drink it all before I
walk back then the next night we went
into we went into town well in the
afternoon and there's this restaurant on
the beach called is highly recommended
called the office a beautiful place like
I mean there's all these seats on the
sand of the beach and then people are
walking by and you're like watching the
sunset it's beautiful I was like Oh put
us right here on the edge of the beach
that's in like downtown Cabo yeah and
almost a little bit off of it a little
bit south of like the downtown area been
recommended it cuz he went down there a
few weeks ago because I would not
recommend the restaurant that I went to
yeah this one was good I tell you so I'm
like Oh put us right here down at the
edge of the beach like right the first
table because they didn't want to put us
there and
it turns out there's a reason because
once you sit down there it's like I'm
I'm I'm getting a margarita and Chrissy
and I are taking some pictures and just
lovey-dovey in on each other just having
a great old time and I'm looking out at
the view and then all of a sudden people
start walking up guys women kids selling
stuff like blocking my view like
cramping my style
and I'm talking cotton candy I'm like
I'm out of Austria I'm at a restaurant
and the dude had like cotton candy and
then there's people with like making
bracelets and and a guy comes up and
he's any mean and he looks at me and he
says he gave two signals he said do you
want smoke and or do you want blow and
he did the thing with his mouth with the
smoke and they needed a thing with his
nose for the blow and I'm like I don't
know I don't know exactly what you
referred to about I think I do and no we
don't so I didn't I didn't get any of
that I already have a blow dryer that's
right yeah and I don't smoke it's not
good for you both of those things
covered but then somebody came up this
woman came up and she had all of these
like I thought they were banners cuz
they each said something different one
of them and then I'm like these are
wearable they're like sashes you can I
buy a sash and one of them said but
stuff yeah they said all types of stuff
that's what one of them said and another
one said bushi oh I almost bought that
one yeah
I thought that would be funny for my
Instagram but then I'm like I don't know
what that means I looked at on urban
dictionary and bushy either means
stuck-up or it could mean stupid and I I
didn't really believe that's what it
said night I like wiped it out of my
memory not text to Christie before we
came in here I was like what did the
banner say she said one of them said
bushy and I was like are you sure that
you haven't got long yes
I mean I can think of some other things
it means I don't but it's not the kind
of thing you know but that's what every
war that's well I theory irreverent type
stuff that like for some reason people
would be compelled to buy another in
Cabo king of but stuff I don't I don't
do they give you a crown with it there's
the king of but stuff and whatever he
wants to blow it's an interesting place
down there man yeah it is I didn't I did
agree I just wanted him to move yeah
yeah and I mean I am I'm currently
buying something man right I am in the
process of buying something I sell me
something else right now I would still
recommend the restaurant but I wouldn't
recommend going all the way down to the
beach yeah and then I remember been
warning me about that but I was so
enamored by the beach that I forgot that
yeah even they didn't want to sit BC and
they know that yeah they know that yeah
bushy be I'll say one of the one last
thing about the the trip to Mammoth and
that is we're trying to figure out what
to do in the evenings you know the the
slopes closed like 4:00 or 4:30 Sun Goes
Down pretty early we would go out to eat
right after that and you know it's our
two families kind of kind of hanging out
so there's like nine of us total may I
recommend but stuff you can recommend
I'm not gonna take that recommendation
and I'm not trying to be weird I don't
even know what that means it's just on a
battery Cabo manlier so I was like what
are we gonna do and III think it may
have been Oh we were on we went on
Netflix trying to figure out what we're
going to to watch now you got it
and they're promoting Monty Python and
the Holy Grail or it was like coming up
and suggested based on whoever's profile
it was that we were using which was the
person who had stayed there before us or
maybe the owner I don't know oh okay you
know when you log in you're like who's
watching Kurt Susan
bill none none of the above
we'll pick Kurt Kurt with the K because
that
risky we're gonna screw Kurtz watching
history but Ralph is like let's watch
list let's watch Monty Python in the
Holy Grail
with the kids and see how the humor
translates yeah which I thought was an
excellent idea
yeah he's talking British you're also
talking like mmm this is 70s yeah 1974 I
believe yeah so teenage kids go upstairs
immediately out Oh a little disappointed
but so now we have we've got the younger
kids Jesse's not in there
Jesse even more reading Jesse and
Heather are kind of half watching but
also like on on the internet okay yeah
yeah it kind of doing that thing yeah
but Ralph and I and then Shepherd and
Ian are all committed to Monty Python
and I'm watching them watch it because
I've seen this movie several times I'm
reminded when I watch it just how a how
funny it is be how it could never be
made today its irreverent it's very
irreverent I mean I politically
incorrect I don't I've not watched it
all in one sitting I've seen many scenes
well it it's uh the next night we
watched Life of Brian which is
significantly more irreverent and
politically incorrect it was made in 79
so you know you know I'm not sure when
the other one was made but because
there's like three in it series what
right but anyway they the kids like
we're like looking at each other
giggling laughing like all that you know
the talk about the you know the Africans
swallow or the European swallow and all
these first of all years remember how
many things in comedy are kind of based
on the way that these guys thought yeah
and the way they presented things how
many memes there are based on this and
just especially the Holy Grail is this
this this scene after scene that you
could sort of see the way that they
thought about this like we're gonna go
and then there's gonna be this
interaction which is based on this that
we think will be funny the Knights
Hussein EEP or whatever and like if it
very simple devices that were just kind
of running to the ground and very
satisfying ways
kids were completely into it the whole
time which was crazy to me and but then
we watched the Life of Brian the next
night and they had pushed that they push
things a little bit further by the time
hmm
life or Brian came out and so sort of
inadvertently showed our youngest kids a
naked woman on screen for the first time
so well this gave them that exist Swiss
friend I'm sure didn't care no for
Switzerland there everybody's naked
they're surprised in a big deal a lot of
snow and a lot of nakedness it doesn't
add up but there's this moment where you
know Brian's girlfriend we're not really
a girlfriend just sort of a hookup
it's really we describe it he's is naked
and I saw it and I was like you know I'm
how do I react in this moment like
because I could do the thing where I
acts like Oh
Shepherd cover your eyes which in my
mind is communicating oh there's a
woman's body you should be afraid of it
mm-hmm so I was like I'm not gonna do
that this is I'm not gonna overreact so
I just kind of sat there and I just sort
of looked at him you looked at him I
just looked at him and he had this he
just had this smile on his face like
like a guilty smile like oh my god no
I'm not supposed to see that and it was
over before he knew it and the next day
I I asked him what he thought about it
and he was like it was weird
okay the whole movie or that moment that
moment
oh but anyway they thought they actually
if you're if you're gonna watch one of
them with your small children I might
recommend the Holy Grail instead of life
O'Brien lifer Brian also is just a
little more the the the jokes are not as
simple you know it's it's it's a well I
don't know because I am on all different
level but it you know
Shepard got Lando to watch a movie that
then we left your house so we couldn't
finish watching so
yesterday morning I in order to get him
to leave without the movie being over I
told him that I'd watch it with him and
it was the Pink Panther original no not
the original that was with Peter Sellers
this was Pink Panther with Steve Martin
Steve Martin yeah which is the remake
from the 90s I'd never seen it but
assist been remade again right I don't
know but he he he came up first thing in
the morning got in the bed with me and
Christine looks at me and he's like you
ready to watch the movie and I'm like oh
yeah I did promise that so like first
thing o to finish them yesterday morning
no we started it over and have you seen
it I I'm not sure it was really funny
man I mean i-i've been deprived of a lot
of comedy and I realized like I just I
didn't think I would find it funny
because it's like a lot of slapstick and
it's very but there's a whole layer of
smart baked into how this thing was
written I only got 21 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes but you know what I'm taking
back what I said when it comes to comedy
probably horror - it's not reliable I
think that at least the first half of
that movie is is if you're in the right
frame of mind and you take it for what
it is is very funny
it is very smart the way that they have
executed something that is so uh well
not stupid but oblivious this character
very funny man I highly recommend it we
had a blast the two of us just cackling
and I saw I'll credit Shepherd for that
he's a great he loved that movie critic
um
2006 thanks Jenna so yeah came out to
that some so yeah not even in the
nineties that was a sequel that we
haven't watched yet but maybe we'll
watch that that's not our
recommendations now should we see should
we go to that let's put a capper on what
we've learned from our vacations Fire
and Ice I think your ego at the door
well again my mission your mission was
to relax my mission was was to prepare
for a longer trip and I was a little bit
worried about like you know so call
it was difficult conditions great
conditions but difficult conditions is
Shepard going to be you know kids at
that age they can go one of two ways
they can sort of recoil from it and sort
of go into themselves and then you're
like oh crap I've already paid for this
week long vacation in Colorado and now
I'm the only one that wants to do it
when we left the mountain on the last
day Shepard was like do we have to leave
one more run dad and so he's on board he
was he was the one that I was worried
about right that's good I mean you did
sweeten the deal with the topless woman
right now he just thinks that every time
we go to the mountains we ski during the
day and then we watch naked ladies at
night and I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
I'll have to you know correct that
vision I feel like there are some things
that have been discussed in this episode
that we're gonna have to apologize for
but not and what I the banner you're not
a bushy yeah I I might be still don't
know anything no to the banner makes you
a bushy right did you learn anything
else no I just learned what happened
with you Rex in effect check baby check
baby 1 2 3 4 check baby 1 2 I've got a
red big check
I watched during the probably 20th hours
of flight that we that we took to and
from London I watched the entire Waco
series may have heard about this Waco
Texas so it's down it's on
I think it's on paramount like pay the
paramount Network which a lot of people
don't have but they're trying some
things you know they're trying to
establish themselves this is the Branch
Davidians what what well they don't call
themselves a cult but well that's what
the US government well so they took all
these over Delhi I call
so you remember David Koresh the Branch
Davidians early 90s there was a how many
days would you have said that the
standoff between the Branch Davidians
and the government was because you were
we were in high school at the time I
remember hearing about it on the news
but was you guess I talked about it a
long time but I I mean I'm just gonna
guess 7 days 50 days
50 day 51 days there was a standoff and
it was a really interesting time first
of all you know I think that back in the
let me just say that Taylor Kish however
you say his name of Friday Night Lights
Fame my eggs plays David Koresh and he's
excellent he's really really good very
compelling and there's other like kind
of a who's who of like sort of
supporting actors from other shows I'm
glad he did good because he did bad hit
me well he was in that Disney movie that
cost a whole lot of money oh that was a
little bit of an embarrassment and that
yeah that kind of but he was great in
this showed a lot of versatility it's
very difficult to be like taken
seriously and like to be this like
compelling character with a mullet in
that way and he just kind of nailed it
and but like they both the the side
piece from house of cards like clear
Underwood side piece that guy was in it
and then Supergirl was in it then the
blonde curly headed girl from Ozark it's
just there's a lot of people you oh that
guy from that that girl from this and I
thought they did it I I in really
enjoyed it cuz I like the historical
aspect but the interesting thing about
it is that there's the story that the
FBI and the ATF kind of put out about
what happened which is the story that as
a kid in the 90s listening to the news
you get you get the government story and
I'm not much of a conspiracy theorist as
much as I like to say things like
Finland doesn't exist for funsies on GMM
I'm really not really prone to believe
conspiracies but it's interesting
because the whole series is from the
perspective of the FBI negotiator who
basically got kicked off of the job
towards the end and a guy named David
Thibodeau who was one of the cult
members who got out and kind of made it
out of this thing alive and basically
it's like you heard that this was all
the stuff that was happening but this is
our perspective on what happened so I'm
sure that it's biased I'm sure that it's
not true 100% true but you've got sort
of the government story and then you've
got the Branch Davidians story and it's
just very interesting to see that
back to you're like oh this kind of
makes me I wonder what actually went
down but I recommend it it's only six
episodes so it's one of those things
there's not too much of a commitment to
just see the story played out and it's
well executed so are you a branch
davidian now no I'm definitely not a
branch davidian David Koresh was very
wack and did a bunch of really
ridiculous things but I don't
necessarily think that they should have
been you know executed by the government
mmm that's the wreck for this week how's
that your biscuits let us know what you
think about I don't know chains on tires
anything else that you want to you want
to throw out there at us let's keep the
conversation going and you know what you
can count on us to speak at you next
week most likely about our experience in
London we learned a lot we experienced a
lot we shared it with each other but now
we need to share with you yes
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best